and I think that's what we're struggling
with right now with climate conversation
it's become about this you've got to you
know eat less you've got to travel less
you've got to you know be a little
colder a little poorer it's going to be
a little more uncomfortable but at least
we'll save the planet most people are
just not going to say yes to that and
certainly not in Africa and India
elsewhere what we will solve the climate
crisis with or I'm not going to say
climate crisis the climate problem
is by focusing on Innovation imagine if
we could innovate say fourth generation
nuclear to be cheaper than fossil fuels
yeah ever everyone would switch you
wouldn't have to have all these Grand
meetings in Paris and everywhere else
you just simply see Nations across the
world switch